Second kind of middleware is MOM, okay, Message-Oriented Middleware. Here we
are thinking about asynchronous message passing. Each of the pieces acts more or
less autonomally, autonomously sending out messages when it needs to.
These messages are queued up, so, we have some degree of fault tolerance because
if a piece goes down the informa, the messages it has to deal with are still
in the queue. And when it comes back up it can peel them off the queue.
Message-Oriented Middleware is not particularly transparent
because the clients must implement the coordination embedded in these messages.
So messages not only transmit data, they also transmit information about
about state. Some of the products that are involved here include IBM's MQSeries,
SUN's Java Message Queues and and some of Amazon Queuing Solutions.